Ki Linux is a specialized lenux
distributor design for ethical hacking
penetration testing and cyber security
it offers a wide range of pre-installed
security tools customization options and
life boot capabilities making it go to
choice for Professionals in this field
always remember to use Ki Linux
ethically and legally Ki Linux is the
major ask for Recruiters in the ethical
hacking domain so if you are looking to
learn Kali Linux and get certified into
ethical hacking explore the wide range
of cyber security and ethical hacking
courses by simply learn these courses
are handcrafted by the industry experts
from the best universities across the
globe by enrolling in cyber security
courses by simply learn you will be
skilled in advanc hacking Concepts
Network hacking analysis firewalls and
honeypots network security cryptography
and more an year of experience is
required to enroll in this course find
the course Link in the description box
so without without any further delay
let's begin welcome back to Simply
learns YouTube channel ethical hacking
is the practice of using hacking
techniques to test the security of a
computer system Network or application
with the goal of identifying
vulnerabilities and improving the
overall security of the system with
increasing Reliance on digital systems
in various Industries there has been a
growing demand for skilled ethical
hackers ethical hacking offers a
lucrative career option with a high
salary and the potential to work as a
freelancer or as a part of te with that
being said it is sufficiently evident
that cyber security and ethical hacking
are amazing career options for every
individual out there so without any
further delay let's jump onto our topic
right away if you want to enter the
field of cyber security and grab a
high-paying job then simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you this
postgraduate program in cyber security
will help you learn comprehensive
approaches to protecting your
infrastructure and securing data data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you'll get foundational to
advanc skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
this program for admission to this
postgraduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
grades and candidates with one plus year
of work experience are preferred so join
now the course link is mentioned in the
description box below let us start by
understanding what ethical hacking is
ethical hacking often referred to as
Whitehead hacking involves using your
cyber security skills to protect systems
and networks in 2024 this field is more
critical than ever due to the increasing
number of cyber attacks your role as an
ethical hacker is to find
vulnerabilities before malicious hackers
do and secure digital environments
before we begin let's talk about the
prerequisites to excel in ethical
hacking you should have a strong
foundation in computer science or it
familiarity with programming languages
like python C++ and Java will be
beneficial as they are commonly used in
cyber security tasks it's essential to
follow a structured learning path so
start by gaining a deep understanding of
networking you need to comprehend how
data flows through networks the various
protocols in use and security mechanisms
that protect them next delve into the
world of operating systems understanding
the inrees of most popular operating
systems like Windows Linux and Mac OS is
crucial for ethical hacker
you'll often encounter vulnerabilities
at this level certifications play a
pivotal role in your ethical hacking
career consider pursuing certifications
like certified ethical hacker certified
information system Security
Professionals CompTIA Security Plus and
certified information security manager
cism these certifications are recognized
by industry professionals and can open
up doors to many exciting job
opportunities learning by doing is
crucial in ethical hacking engage in
Hands-On experiences such as capture the
flat competitions participating in bug
bounties and setting up your own home
lab these activities will sharpen your
practical skills and deepen your
understanding of vulnerabilities and
exploits cyber security is a rapidly
evolving field stay updated with the
latest threats tools and techniques by
following cyber security news attending
conferences and engaging with online
communities the ability to adapt to New
Challenges is a Hallmark of a successful
ethical hacker ethical hacking is all
about doing good always are there to the
law obtain proper permission when
testing systems and respect privacy and
confidentiality ethical behavior is not
just a requirement it's a Cornerstone of
this profession as you progress build a
strong portfolio document your
achievements successful hacks and
projects a well-maintained portfolio
will not only showcase your skill but
also make you stand out to potential
employers building strong networking
skills is essential attend cyber
security conferences and join
professional associations like Issa
information system security Association
or
isaca information systems audit and
Control Association networking not only
enhances your knowledge but also opens
doors to job opportunities and
collaborations coding and scripting are
your secret weapons Master scripting
languages like Python and Powershell
these skills are invaluable when
automating security tasks creating
custom tools and analyzing malwares
incident response is a critical aspect
of cyber security understand how to
detect respond to and recover from
security incidents familiarize yourself
with incident response Frameworks like
nist and ISO
271 this expertise is highly sought
after by organizations looking to
Bluster their cyber defenses don't
underestimate the importance of soft
skills effective communication teamwork
and problem solving abilities will set
you apart in the workplace ethical
hackers often collaborate with cross
functional teams and strong
interpersonal skills are essential for
success in this ever evolving field
continuous learning is your best friend
stay curious and explore some emerging
Technologies like Ai iot and Quantum
Computing as they bring new security
challenges learning about these
Technologies and their Associated
security risks will make you an
invaluable asset to any
organization join online communities and
forums where ethical hackers share
knowledge and experiences platforms like
GitHub and overflow can be invaluable
for collaboration and learning engaging
with the community allows you to tap
into the collective wisdom of
experienced hackers looking ahead
consider specializations with ethical
hacking such as mobile security iot
security or Cloud security these niches
offer exciting career paths and
opportunities to become an expert in a
specific area of cyber security if you
want to start your career in ethical
hacking you might be confused with the
variety of certifications being offered
in the the market today from Network
specialist to system administrator
ethical hacking has become necessary in
today's digital driven world with every
factor of business moving to the cloud
with jobs in every department and the
competition certifications are the best
way to demonstrate your knowledge and
skill in the potential employer and
stand out from the crowd in this video
we will talk about the best
certifications that you should aim if
you want to get into ethical hacking
however if you want a comprehensive
Solution on how to prepare yourself for
these exams check out the cyber security
expert Masters program which will give
you the knowledge and abilities that you
should need to excel in this quickly and
expanding field with the best in-class
program you will discover through
methods of safeguarding your
infrastructure such as preventing data
and information constructing risk
analysis
mitigation architecting cloud-based
security achieving complaints and much
more so let's begin with the first and
probably the most well-known and well
regarded certification in the ethical
hacking sector which is none other than
c or certified ethical hacker but before
that let's discuss the agenda for this
slide so first we'll discuss what is
ethical hacking now after that we'll see
what is certified ethical hacker moving
ahead we'll discuss about OSP which is
offensive security certified
professional after that we'll see
certified information system security
professional which is
cisp after that we'll talk about com Tia
Security Plus certification after that
we'll see certified Cloud security
professional now let's see what is
ethical hacking so what is ethical
hacking basically it's when a computer
expert tries to hack into a system or
network in order to find any valab or
weaknesses that a Mis Lous hacker could
exploit the difference is that ethical
hackers do it with permission from the
owner of the system and they don't use
their skills to do any harm so why is
ethical hacking important well as we do
more and more online the risk of cyber
attacks increases cyber crimes can steal
our personal information money and
identities ethical hacking helps to
protect us from these attacks by finding
weaknesses in our systems before that
bad guys can exploit them that you know
about ethical hacking let's start with
the certifications so the first one is
certified ethical hacking C
certification so this certification is
for people who want to learn how to
think like a hacker to protect computer
systems better it covers topics such as
scanning system hacking Torin back doors
viruses and bombs and social engineering
to earn the C certification you need to
pass an exam now I'll tell you about the
course that we are offering so in order
to better defend business infrastructure
from data breaches you will learn the
sophisticated step-by-step purchases
used by hackers in this certified
ethical hacking 12 okay I'll tell you
about that so this is the program C
version 12 certified ethical hacker
right this course will cover topics like
information security overview and then
it will start telling you about
information security threads and attack
vectors penetration testing comp
Concepts hacking Concepts ethical
hacking Concepts information security
control and there are so many other
modules also that you can see here on
your screens so this is what you will
learn about from this course so the link
will be in the the description box don't
worry about the link you will also see
there will be live classes on every
weekday for this see there will be
weekly classes starting from the date
you will join after that so there will
be weekly classes for this course and
also we will so whenever you will take
this course you'll have to take the CH
exam so for that we'll give you the exam
voucher with this course as it's
mentioned here also on our
screens that will give exam voucher for
C right so now we have offensive
security certified professional which is
OSP
certification it's a highly respected
and practically certification in the
field of cyber security offensive
security a leading provider of
information security training and
penetration testing services offers it
the oscp certif ification test an
individual's ability to identify and
exploit variabilities in the controlled
and safe environment the Hands-On
certification required the candidates to
complete a 24 hours penetration testing
exam on a simulated Network followed by
a report on their findings to prepare
for the OSP certification candidate must
complete the offensive security
certified professional course this
course also includes video lectures and
practical exercises and candidates must
demonstrate their skills through a
series of lab exercises employers highly
value the OSP certification as it
demonstrate the candidates ability to
think outside the box problem solve and
work independently it is also a
prerequisite for many high level cyber
security jobs such as penetration tester
ethical hacker in summary the CB
certification is challenging and
practically require Hands-On skills and
a strong understanding of cyber security
Concepts it's a highly requested in the
industry and can lead to many exciting
and well-paying job opportunities the
best part about the OSP certification is
the similarity it has with C when it
comes to curricular so learning the
technical aspects of one is sure to
prepare you for the other with very
little efforts so you can take a c
course from Simply learn and you can
also learn after that the OSP because
it's very similar to that okay now let's
talk about the
cissp so certified information system
security professional certification this
is one of the most well-known and
respected certification in the field it
covers a wide range of topics including
security and risk management asset
security security architecture and
engineering communication and network
security identity and access management
security assessment and testing and many
more to earn the cissp certification you
need to have at least 5 years of
experience in the field and pass an exam
so you need to pass an exam of cissp so
now let me open the cissp course for you
so we have this cisp training course you
can take up this course the link will be
in the description box and let me tell
you about the cissp okay so yeah this
cissp certification is regarded as The
Pinacle of achievement in information
security the cissp course will prepare
you to become an information assurance
expert who defines all areas of it
security including architecture design
management and controls it is aligned
with ISC to cbk standards start with
cissp training now because the majority
of it Security Professionals favor or
require a CSP certification you will
cover topics like I'll tell you about
the content of the course so you will
cover topics like this domain One
Security and risk management asset
security communication and network
security and there are so many domains
and in this you will learn so many other
things so this is Will definitely going
to help you the link will be in the
description box do check it out click on
the uh link and you will open that this
page will be open for you guys and you
can enroll here give your name number
and email ID and submit and our experts
will contact you for sure okay now also
there will be live classes on weekends
for this so to check it out the link
will be in the description box a CIS
sp's annual total income is expected to
be
$13,000 in the US and with the average
salary of
$82,000 now we'll move on to the CompTIA
Security Plus certification so this
certification cover various topics
including threads attacks Technologies
and tools architecture and design
identity and access management risk
management and cryptography to earn the
CompTIA Security Plus certification you
you need to pass an exam now I'll tell
you about this com Tia Security Plus
exam in further so com Tia Security Plus
certification covers various topics
including threads attacks Technologies
and tools architecture and design
identity and exess management risk
management and cryptography to earn the
com Tia Security Plus certification you
need to pass an exam now I'm going to
tell you about this course comti
Security Plus which is offered by simply
learn it's a Wily recognized
certification comti Security Plus
verifies fundamentals of vendor neutral
it security knowledge and abilities this
certification program covers the
fundamental concepts of network security
and risk management as a benchmark for
best practice in it security the classes
of this will be held on weekends and you
can also check what you are covering in
this course in this course content page
okay you will find everything here like
attack HS and these are the things that
you will learn governments risk and
complaints this is the things that you
going to learn around this course okay
so now is the best time to learn this
you can take up this course the link
will be in the description box below
click on the and enroll now I have told
you how to enroll in this course so now
let's move forward to
ccsp okay so this this ccsp which is
stands for certified Cloud security
professional is last on our list so
let's move on to ccsp if you are
interested in Cloud security and you may
want to consider the certified Cloud
security professional certification this
certification covers topics such as
cloud data security Cloud platform and
infrastructure security Cloud
application security operations legal
and complaints and risk management to
ear the ccsp certification you need to
have at least 5 years of experience in
the field and to pass an exam the top
certification offered by ISC 2 is the
certified Cloud security professional
training program by comprehens
information security concerns and
putting data protection policies into
practice this training will help you
reduce security threats to your cloud
storage so I'm going to show you so
there will be some other courses also
that you can take when you will take up
this course there are uh certified Cloud
security professional com Tia Network
plus
cism uh if you're going for ethical
hacking you should take cism but it's up
to you guys you if you want to take
security uh uh Cloud security
professional course you can take that
this three are elective ones you can
choose any one of them okay
hey everyone it's no secret that the
majority of our internet usage is at the
risk of being hacked be it via unsafe
messaging applications or misconfigured
operating systems to counteract this
void of digital security penetration
testing has become the norm when it
comes to vulnerability assessment K
Linux is an operating system that has
become a well-known weapon in this fight
against hackers a Linux distribution
that is made specifically for
penetration testers K Linux has layers
of features that we will be covering in
today's lesson let's take a look at the
topics to be covered in this
video we start by learning about K Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of K Linux
from the story of its origin to its
current day
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Kali that make it an
attactive choice for penetration testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start our journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an open-
Source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
ious information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiple
platform solution accessible and freely
available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the k
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
noex as can be inferred from the name it
was based on the npix operating system
as its underlying OS poix had released
ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as wax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
KNIX to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using
knopic its efforts were combined with
backs to produce backtrack backtrack was
based on slackware from version one to
version 3 but switched to Ubuntu later
on with version 4 to version five using
the experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when khi Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than 600 penetration
tools pre-installed after reviewing
every tool that was included in
backtrack developers have eliminated a
great number of tools that either simply
did not work or which duplicated other
tools that provided the same or similar
functionality the Khali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individuals
who are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
repositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that ki's armm support would need to be
as robust as they could manage with
fully working
installations K Linux is available on a
wide range of armm devices and has armm
repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal Linux
is by launching the distribution in the
live USB mode this can be AED by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the K Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hard
disk installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the allotted
Ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest guest operating system like K
Linux allows users a safe environment to
learn while not putting the systems at
risk if you want to learn more about how
one can go forward with this method we
have a dedicated video where Ki Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install Ki
Linux is by using a dual boot system to
put it in simple words the Ki Linux OS
will not be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
alloted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system there are multiple ways
to install K Linux we can either install
it on a normal hard drive in a virtual
machine software such as VMR or virtual
box or we can do that in hard bare metal
machines now for the convenience of
explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is able
to run multiple operating systems on a
single host machine which in our case is
a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file we go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on the
download button we can see we have a
window archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMS side
of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but for right now in the case of K Linux
the third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has a a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution Kus is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
fold fer but anywhere you put it will
hold up all the information of the
operating system all the files you
download all the configurations you
store everything will be stored in this
particular location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the dis capacity this dis capacity
will be all the storage that will be
provided to your virtual machine of K
Linux think of your Windows device if
you have a 1 TB of hard drive you have
the entirety of the hard disk to store
data on how much data you give here you
can only store up to that amount of data
not to mention some amount of capacity
will be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications for now we can give around
let's say 15 GB of information or if a
recommended size for D is 20 you can
just go ahead at 20 it depends all on
the user case if you're going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applic applications
and perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual diss as a single file or
storing them into multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on
VMware sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out with the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8 GB or below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system if the memory has some amount of
free storage left let's say on idle
storage my Windows machine takes about 2
GB so I have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6gb
it'll be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as 2
GB of memory for the virtu machine
instance similarly we can use the number
of processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we're going to select
use ISO image file we're going to click
on
browse going and go to downloads and
select the IMO file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that we're going to wait for the things
to load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system
for this we can go with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always prefer to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a land cable let's say if we
use the name
Kali domain name name you we can skip it
for now it's not necessary as such for
the
installation this is the full name for
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here
there are multiple options like the use
entire disk use entire dis and set up
lvm use entire dis and set up encrypted
lvm for newcomers it is recommended to
just use the first one since lvm
encryption is something that you can
learn afterwards when you're much more
handson with the Linux operating system
for now we're going to use the use
entire dis guided installation and press
on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on vmw we had set up a dis
capacity that we propose 20gb that is
the hard disk which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk on
VMR it acts as a normal hard disk on
which an operating system can be
installed so we select this one and
press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gp dis
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the number
amount of ram provided the processors
provided and how quickly the performance
of the system is being hampered by the
host machine on quicker systems this
will be rather quick while on the
smaller ones this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
install external applications which are
not installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time it ask us
to select a network mirror we're going
to select as yes and move forward with
this next it's going to ask us for an
HTTP proxy which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the K Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the graub boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gr loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the grub bootloader is
being installed the grub is highly
essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are incorrect order the absence of a
boot loader will not be able to launch
the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file and since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before here we're going to enter our
username and password that we had set up
before and we have the color system
booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analyst
worldwide all of these come
pre-installed with K Linux and others
can be installed using the AP package
manager that we had
configured we can see a full name over
here
and with this our installation of the Ki
Linux is complete so if you are looking
to learn ki Linux and get certified into
ethical hacking explore the wide range
of cyber security and ethical hacking
courses by simply learn find the course
Link in the description box basics of K
Linux let us take a look at the agenda
for our demo
today we start out with a few terminal
commands that are a basic part of a
Linux operating
system the configure our own proxy
chains to maintain anonymity while
running penetration testing attacks on
our
victims next we run a few n map scans on
a local Windows 10 machine to find out
the type of information that can be
gathered in such a
scenario moving on we use y Shar to
monitor internet traffic and understand
the importance of encryption and
security when browsing the worldwide web
next we learn about metas spit and its
various applications in the line of
vulnerability assessment of a device and
finally we use mloy to take root access
of a fully updated Windows 10 computer
system let's begin with some terminal
Basics on K
Linux when most people hear the term
Linux they Envision a complex operating
system used only by programmers however
the experience is not as frightening as
it appears Linux is an umbrella term for
a collection of free and open source
Unix operating systems there are many
variants like Ubuntu Fedora de
these are distributions which is will be
a more precise term when using a Linux
operating system you will most likely
utilize a shell which is a command line
interface that provides access to the
operating system Services the majority
of Linux distributions shipped with a
graphical user interface also known as
GUI as their primary shell this is done
to facilitate user interaction in the
first place having said that a command
line interface is suggested due to its
increased power and effectiveness by
entering the commands into the CLI tasks
that require a multi-step GUI procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
you can start the terminal by clicking
on the prompt icon here on
top once the terminal is open we can put
up our commands the First Command that
we are going to look into is PWD PWD
stands for present working
directory as of right now what you're
seeing is the terminal window by default
if I write PWD and press enter this
shows the directory in which the
terminal is being run on as of right now
it's in the NF folder of my desktop
which is specifically this folder if I
open up this folder you can see it is
currently empty as in it has no contents
if I use another command known as
mkdir which is supposed to stand for
make directory and I write nf2 shortage
for new folder
2 if I open up the NF F you can see the
new folder is created this is how the
PWD command Works another important
command to change directories it's
called the CD command let's say right
now if I am in NF I want to create a new
file in nf2 folder or something else in
the nf2 folder I have to shift to CD
nf2 Now if I write
PWD it will show the present working
directory of Home simply learn desktop
NF and inside that I am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate through the Linux
files and dis directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this for now CD
Works another few commands is we can
write CD dot dot and it will come back
one folder now the PWD will be just NF
and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go a different file let's say if
we just go for
CD
home simply
learn that's
it right now these are the folders in
our current present working directory we
have the desktop the documents downloads
Etc from here we can again go to the
desktop using the same CD
command cross check the changing of
directories and check the files again
and yes there we go NF how do we know
this what are the command that I used to
show the files and folders that folder
is known as the ls command LS can be
used to view the contents of a directory
by default this command will display the
contents of your current working
directory if we add some other
parameters we can find the contents of
other directories as well there are some
hidden files as well in Linux which
cannot be showed just with ls for
example if you just go to CD Etc which
is a configuration folder for Linux if
you write LS now these are the files
that can be
seen if we want to see the hidden files
we'll have to add one more parameter
here like LS minus a and as you can see
the number of files have increased this
time
around there are other things as well
that we can see with Linux LS minus a L
will show the hidden files along with
some of the parameters and some of the
permissions that has been provided for
each file as you can see many of these
files have root access some of them can
write some of them can read it differs
file to file and the ls minus Al command
is used to check each of these files
permission and change them accordingly
if
needed the next command that we can look
for is the cat command or
concatenate it is one of the most
frequently used commands and it is used
to list the contents of a file on the
output for example let's say if I have a
file at the
desktop in this nf2 folder I will create
a
document create an empty
file e
file I'll open up the document and I'll
write it as hello KH
I will save this
up now to change the directories from
Etc to nf2 we have already discussed how
to use the CD command using just the
folder name now if you want to go to the
entire directory we can write CD home as
you can see it is already prompting us
to complete the name of the directory at
this point we just have to press tab and
it completes it for ourself next we
already know we have to enter the
desktop NF and
nf2 and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press LS we
can find a file over here now as
discussed for the concatenate it is used
to show the contents of a file so right
now if we press cat which stands for
concatenate e file as you can see we
have written hello khi in the text file
and we can see the output right now we
can also use it to create new files for
example if you write
cat any file name such as e File
2 here we can write anything hello Kali
again once we press contrl C here we can
check eile 2 and we have hello Kali
again printed over here we can see the
same using the con cenate command as
well if I press LS you can see we have
two files here and I can go with cat e
File 2 and I have Hello Kali again this
is how the concatenate command Works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
CP which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mind you this is
not moving this is only going to copy
the command for example currently our
PWD which is the present fcking
directory is in the nf2 folder as you
can see over
here let's copy the E file tool to the
NF folder we can write
CP e File 2 and give the path of the NF
folder which will be
home simply
learn textop
nnf now if I press LS I'll find both the
files and nf2 since I
copied to go back to the NF folder again
we can again use the same command
of no we can again use the home simply
learn
ttop and just NF no nf2 this time just
NF as you can see this will change back
our present working directory now when
we press LS we will find the eile to
file and the nf2 folder and we can
confirm this using the GUI as well this
is the NF folder and you can see the NF
to folder and the E File 2 document if I
write cat e File
2 Cat eile 2 we can see the contents of
the file now this can be done using
moving as well for example if I go to CD
nf2 which is the inside folder it has
both the document files like e file and
E File 2 let's say I want to move the E
file completely from nf2 to NF1 instead
of writing CP the command I'm going to
use is MV MV e file and again give the
path of the folder into which I have to
copy which will be again
home simply
learn
desktop and NF as you can see the
contents of the nf2 have appeared here
and E file has been moved from nf2 to
NF this is the nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press CD dot dot
and we go back to NF LS right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and E File 2 that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple oneline
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using GUI this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for Linux
operating systems
another very important command for Linux
operating system is the pseudo command
pseudo is short for super user do the
command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions you can think of it as how
we run programs as administrator on
Windows systems it is not advisable to
use this command for daily use because
it might be easy for an error to occur
and the permissions of root are very
intricate so new beginners are advised
to use the pseudo command only when
absolutely necessary for example pseudo
Su with this command I am giving this
terminal a root permission this Su
stands for this
user at this point it's going to ask for
my admin
password once I enter my
password and I now have root access note
how the password that I entered did not
show up here this is a security measure
to prevent people from snooping on on
your root password which is the end game
of all this operating system as you also
can see the symbol changed if the dollar
symbol is showing it's source as a
standard user when you switch to root
you can easily see a hash
symbol this opens up a separate shell
inside this terminal command for example
we can exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the K Linux system we have
to use a
update as you can see it says problem
unlinking the file because permission
denied now let's try this using
pseudo pseudo APD
update as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the
system this can be done using either
writing the sudo command every time we
want to perform a root access or we can
just write pseudo Su once and write AP
update
alone the fetching is complete over
here for the second example let's say I
just write pseudo Su and this time is
not going to ask me the password because
at this current terminal process I've
already provided the ru password once
and it is in memory right now now when
we use to update the system we had to
write pseudo AP update that was because
we were running it as a standard user
now we are running it as a root user so
all we have to write is APD update and
it's going to continue its
work there you
go another command that can be useful is
the Ping command it's pretty
self-explanation not it's going to be
checking the internet connectivity you
can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if there is
a local server on your system which
needs to be pinged then you can check
that for example if we have to write
ping and we can use either IP address or
domain let's say if you want to check
that if we can access google.com using
this K Linux installation or not we can
write ping
google.com and you can see it shows the
bytes being sent and received and and
how much time it took to take up the
request this can be done for local
systems as well for example this
installation of K Linux is being run on
a virtual machine once this machine is
running I still have my host machine
running over here the IP address of
which is 192.168
29179 if I try to Ping this from
here as you can see the time to complete
the request is drastically low compared
to a website on the internet considering
this is on the local network this is how
the Ping command is worked and it can
show you what kind of packages are
transmitted how many are received if
there was any kind of packet loss
between the connection window and other
details a very important command when
working with the terminal for a long
duration is a history command pretty
self-explanatory there are so many
commands that are being run some
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did or what was the
directory name they put a history
command helps to recover some of the
commands that you have written it
doesn't go all the way back but it takes
up many commands that were inputed in
the last few processes this is how the
history command works these are some of
the most commonly used terminal commands
if you want to learn more about this
terminal and every other feature of this
please let us know in the comment
section and we'll try to make an
in-depth tutorial special if difficult
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on
Linux moving on we learn how to
configure proxy chains on our
system proxying refers to the technique
of bouncing your internet traffic
through multiple machines to hide the
identity of the original machine it is a
good tool that hackers use to accomplish
this goal is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program through a proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your IP address proxy chain even
allows you to use multiple proxies At
Once by chaining them together one of
the most important reasons that proxy
chains is used in a security context is
that it's easy to evade detection
attackers often use proxies to hide
their true identities while executing an
attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located to to see how proxy chain Works
let's open Firefox first and check our
current IP
address
write
Firefox and there we
go as we can see Firefox is now open
let's check our current IP address right
now if you go to an address called my
ip.com
and you can see it easily detects our
country is in India and this is a public
IP address now if we move to the
terminal
again here we can now
write proxy
chains minus H what this minus H does is
it finds a help it it stands for the
help file this is for help
F what we found out using this is proxy
chains has a config file here Etc proxy
chains 4.co NF this is the config file
found using this config file we can
customize how our proxy change should
work if we want to open that we have to
use it in a text editor on Windows we
have notepad and other things like that
Microsoft Word to edit documents on
Linux we have a tool called Nano to
access the Nano we use the command Nano
and give the path of the file file that
we want to check as of right now the
proxy chain config file is located over
here so we're going to follow the path
there chains 4.
CF and here we go we see the config
file there are three basic types of
proxy chaining here we have a strict
chain where all the proxy in the list
will be used and they will be chained in
order we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy chains
will be done by a random combo of
proxies in the proxy list and you have
Dynamic chain it's the same as strict
chain but dead proxies are excluded from
the
chain and here we can set up whichever
type we want to enable or disable a
particular type we use the hash symbol
here as you can see right now all the
lines have a hashtag symbol at the front
except this one a dynamic chain this is
the current one being used let's say if
I want to use a strict chain method so I
can add a hash value
here and remove the hash here at one
point of time any one of these three
four types should be enabled let's go
for the Dynam um Dynamic
chain we can disable this strict Chain
by putting the hashtag in front and
removing the dynamic chain as you can
see below we have few commands to how to
handle the Nano text editor
this symbol is known as the control
button on your keyboard now if we want
to write out which is synonymous to
saving the file supposed to go with crol
o so if I press CR o on my keyboard it
says file name to write and we have to
press enter here since we want to
overwrite the proxy chain 4. CF file we
don't want to create a new file over
here so just press
enter and we get a permission denied
this permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this using a
standard user Etc is a system folder to
be able to use make some changes we have
to use it using a Pudo command to exit
this Nano we have to use the control X
command we use contr
x we're going to
clear and this time we're going to use
the pseudo command pseudo
Nano
Etc proxy chains
4.
ZF and we have the same file open up
again now this time if you want to make
a change let's say we going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from stract
we're going to use contr o for the save
file option we're going to press enter
and it says R 160 lines again if you
want to reverse this change we put the
hashtag over here enable Dynamic chain
we press CR o press enter and it says
root 160 lines now we can exit straight
away using the CR X
format right now we have not provided
any file or a proxy chain we can have
proxy IP addresses from the internet but
we have to make sure that they are safe
and they don't Snoop on our
data when there is no proxy chains being
provided personally it going it's going
to use the T Network but for that we
have to start t t is a service in Linux
to know more about this tore we can
write sudo system CTL which is used to
know the status of services on the Linux
operating
system and status of
Tor uh system CTL sorry uh instead of
STL it should be system CTL status Tor
as you can see it is a to service
anonymizing overlay Network for TCP
connections and it's currently inactive
now to start this up we have to write
sudo system CTL start T now if we repeat
the same sudo system CTL status store as
you can see it's active
now you can see the green logo over here
okay to integrate the fir Fox and the
browser we can use the proxy chains
command directly over here we can write
proxy chain me we can use Firefox to
launch our web browser and let's say if
we want to visit
google.com we press enter and the
Firefox window is launched and it should
open up google.com next and there we go
if we go to myip.com once
again as you can see we have a different
IP address and the country is unknown as
well so this is how we can use proxy
chains to to anonymize a internet usage
when using G
Linux next on our agenda is the ability
to scan networks using
nmap at its score nmap is a network
scanning tool that uses IP packets to
identify all the devices connected to a
network can learn more about nmap using
the help
file as you can see these are some of
the parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of a system you can see
the version and the URL of the we of the
service over here the primary users of
nmap can be broken into three cow
processes first the program gives you
detailed information on every IP active
on your network and then each IP can
then be scanned secondly it can also be
used to providing a lot of live hosts
and open ports as well as identifying
the OS of every connected device thirdly
nmap has also become a valuable tool for
users looking to protect personal and
business websites using nmap to scan
your own web server particularly if
you're hosting your website from home is
essentially simulating the process that
a hacker would use to attack your site
attacking your own site in this way is a
powerful way of identifying security
vulnerabilities as you already discussed
The Host Windows 10 machine on the
system has an IP address
29179 if you want to to test the OS scan
of the system we're going to first get
the root permission over here we use the
pseudo command and now we are root user
we're going to launch the command n map
minus o which is supposed to be an OS
detection scan the IP address we can use
of the host
system
192.168
29179 in a legitimate penetration
testing scenario we can use the IP
address of the vulnerabil device over
here we are going to let it scan for a
while and it's going to give us some
guesses on what can the OS
be as you can see the scan is done and
it has shown some of the ports that are
open you can see the msrpc port open the
https 443 Port open which is used to
connect to the internet and it has some
aggressive OS guesses as well for
example it thinks there a night 94%
chance that it's going to be a Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack 3 that's partly
because a lot of the Windows XP update
packages are still prevalent on
Windows now that the OS detection is
confirmed there are multiple more
details that we can gather from
nmap let's go with the nmap minus a
command which is supposed to capture as
much data as possible there is also a
speed setting you can call it a speed
setting or a control setting of the
minus t minus t ranges from t 0 to T1 to
T2 all the way up to
T5 this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it'll take more time
to provide the results but it will also
give a less chance for the intrusion
detection system on the vulnerable
machine firewall to detect that someone
is trying to penetrate the network for
now if we want to go with somewhat of a
high speed we can go with the T4 and
provide the same IP address of the local
machine I am trying to attack it's going
to take a little bit of time since it's
trying to capture a lot of
information as you can see the results
are now
here it it launched a scan and took a
few top ports that are most likely
vulnerable from from a Windows XP
perspective and it showed a few ports
over here it has not shown 991 filtered
ports which could not be attacked anyway
since they were closed for outside
access it shows a few fingerprint
settings like the connection policies
and the port
details it shows an HTTP options some
other intricate details that can be used
when you attacking its servers it shows
a VMware version that it's
running and few other ports over
here apart from that we also have the
aggressive OS guesses over here just
like we did with the minus o and you can
see this time it is showing Windows 7 as
98% no exact o matches since uh if there
was any exact o matches we could have
seen a 100% chances over
here this is a trace route a trace route
will be the time and the path a
connection request takes from the source
to the destination for example this
request went from 19 to 16817 2.2 to a
destination address since this is a
local machine it took only a single step
on multiple occasions if you're trying
to access a remote system it's going to
be a number of Trace rots when it jumps
from firewall to firewall and router to
router this is how we can use nmap to
find information about a system and find
some vulnerable ports we can
access moving on we have a tutorial on
how to use W shck to sniff Network
traffic to start using wire shark we're
going to have to open the application
first now during installation of wi
Shack there is an option to enable if
non-root users can be able to capture
traffic or not in my installation I have
disabled that so I will be launching my
Shark when using the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
Wi-Fi
adapter you can see it over here in the
VM tab removable
devices R link a2.1 and W Lan this is a
external Wi-Fi adapter which is inserted
into my USB
system you can see it over here if I
write IW config this is the one dou L
zero this is absolutely necessary
because we need to have have a monitor
mode required we won't need it for
sniffing data on
Yar right now but it's going to be
necessary later on in this tutorial as
well as we will see for now we can just
start up v shark by writing its name on
the command line and it should start the
program here we
go here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposed to
stand for ethn zero Port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select ET
Zer and we have started capturing data
you can see the data request from the
source to destination and the time and
the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as
well as you can see over
here to capture internet traffic we can
try running
Firefox if we just write
wikipedia.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing okay this is spelling mistake
Wikipedia
here you can see the application data of
all these request going up and they
connected to a destination server of 103
16622 4 now if you even if you check the
transmission control protocol Flags over
here and so many more things we cannot
find anything beneficial as you can see
the information over here is gibberish
which is supposed to be since it's
supposed to be
encrypted now this is possible due to
this being an https website hence you
can see the lock symbol over here and
connection is supposed to be secure now
what about HTTP ports we have seen a
many people recommend to not visit HTTP
ports repeat we have seen many people
recommend to not visit HTTP websites and
even if you have to visit to not provide
any critical information for example
let's go to a random
HTTP page over here as you can see this
saying connection is not secure and this
is an HTTP HTTP page and not
https now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say I have a
legitimate account over here if I write
my account
name and my password is supposed to be
password 1 1 2 3 4 I press
login and uh the password does not match
because I do not have an account over
here but let's say I did and I was
logged in as expected we can go to wire
Shack we can use filters over here now
all the requests that I'm sending it's a
TCP request so I can write a filter
containing
TCP
contains whatever string if it is being
passed let's say if for the end username
I write my account name so I can just
write my account name over
here and press enter to find a request
over here now as you can see there are
many flags over here if we go to the HTT
HTML form URL encoded and open up some
of its flags as you can see I can see my
account name and simply learn password
over here this is the
same details that I input on the website
let's say I did have a legitimate
account on this website I would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who would be using wi shark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here this is why it's recommended
to not provide any information on HTTP
Pages the security is not up to the mark
and always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or making any
internet transactions or providing any
information
this is how we can use wire shck to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred through
the network adapter next we have to
learn about what is
Metasploit the Metasploit project is a
computer security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and AIDS in penetration
testing and IDs
development we can open up the terminal
here we're going to allow root
access and to open up Metasploit the
keyword is msf
console it's going to take a little bit
of time to start it
up now the Metasploit console has been
loaded from here we can decide what type
of attack we want to launch and what
kind of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets for example like we
already discussed I'm running this
virtual machine on a Windows 10 host
machine so if I open the command prompt
from my Windows 10 over
here if I need to check the IP address
once I go with ip
config here you can see the IP address
of this local
machine moving
on if we have to attack that machine
let's say we want to see what kind of
exploits are going to work over there
now we already know that Windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the HTA server
vulnerability HTA is supposed to be a
HTML application but when pass the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system to start off with the
Metasploit and accessing such
applications we're going to use the
command use exploit and the name of the
reverse HTA server is this
Windows Misa for
miscellaneous HDA
server as you can see it already found
this
one all right now there are some options
that we need to set for this exploit to
go through for example you can see some
of the options over here there's a
payload the payload is supposed to be
the malicious file that we are going to
send on the HTML application which
allows us to give the back
door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a Windows
meterpreter reverse
TCP completely understandable now let's
set the L host lhost and R host and SRV
host should be the one where we are
going to launch the attack from for
example if we launched another tab of
this
console and we just press I F
config the IP address is 192 + 168
72130 so we're going to set the L host
As
192.168
72130 and we're going to do the same
thing with SRV
host we're going to set a
port where we need to capture the back
door
access
next the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a back door and
give us meter pritter access to the
system meter prer is can be considered
as an upgrade of a normal command prompt
shell we will look into it once we get
the access in the first place now that
we have set the commands we can press on
exploit and press
enter now you can see we have a URL over
here we're going to copy this
URL once the URL is copied we take it
into the browser and paste
it this will ask us to download this
file now as per browser security
settings this file should be blocked by
default we can decide to keep it and
with the correct formulation of this
malicious package even the website
browser antivirus softwares will not be
able to detect good payloads we're going
to save this
file and we're going to open
it publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back to our meter
Peta AIS over here you can see it has
already captured a URL of an HT server
and it is writing delivering
payload just have to wait for a few
seconds the payload is delivered it has
sent this much amount of data meter P
session one is
opened and we should get the access
soon there we go now to understand where
is the session set we can write sessions
minus
I as you can see it has a met over here
we're going to write sessions minus I
the session ID is one so we're going to
write one and we have the meter AIS now
to get a fair idea of the system we're
going to WR s info and it's going to the
computer name the OS architecture all
these things we can write the help
command to see what are the things that
we can get out of the system we can take
screenshots we can control the webcam
and start a video chat we can take a lot
of things over
here there are other commands as well
where we can change the file directory
like the cat command CD command there
are so many things that work in the
normal CMD which we can run on the
metapa as well now if you want to access
this command prompt of the system
directly we can go with this we have to
write
shell and there we go we are in the
downloads folder right now to see if
this is the same computer or not we're
going to write ip
config as you can see it is our M victim
machine with 192 168 but
29.71 we can just press exit and we're
back with the meter prer access this is
how we can use meter prer and metas
to gain access to a Windows 10 machine
next let's take a look at how we can get
root access from a Windows 10
system we just learned how we can get a
meter prer access from our system we can
background this meter prer session by
writing background and pressing enter we
can still we can still see the sessions
sessions minus I it's still present over
here
now these kind of access are not
administrative access these are the kind
of back TOS that can be created for
standard users but to get a complete
access of a system including the program
files the windows documents we need to
have root access or administrative
access to do that we're going to use
another exploit reminder that the meter
session of the standard axis is already
present and we're not messing with it
right now we're going to set up another
session albate with the same
machine that exploit name
is use exploit
Windows
local bypass
USC Event
Viewer and there we go now if we check
the options that we can put in the
system we have to choose an exploit
Target we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
metapa access with the standard user it
doesn't have the system
user we're going to
write set session
one and we're going to run exploit run a
few commands and it open a second meter
session as you can see it is the session
two if I write s
info you can still see I'm not
the um system user right now I'm still
just a normal user how can we check that
if you go to
Shell I still see see users jna
downloads all these
things if I press exit and go back to
the meter P there is a command on meter
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access so if we write get
system
and due to pip impersonation we now have
the system root
access as you can see now it has become
x64 and we are the admin users now if I
go to
Shell I can easily go
back
windows and I can easily access these
things this kind of control over the
window folders and the program files
folders these kind of things are not
possible if you're not an admin access
or the command prompt has not been run
with admin permissions this is how we
can use privilege escalation to get into
an admin access system we used the
second exploit which was the bypass us
Event Viewer exploit and essentially
used it with the first session as you
can read here Windows escalation USA
protection
bypass it was first disclosed on 2016
but it still works on some
systems this is how we can get root
access on our Windows 10
installation so if you are looking to
learn K Linux and get certified into
ethical hacking explore the wide range
of cyber security and ethical hacking
courses by simply learn find the course
Link in the description
box the increasing adoption of cloud
computing Solutions will offer robust
opportunities for more the market of the
forecast period and allow introduction
of newer Technologies the use of cloud
computing Solutions is quickly growing
worldwide owing to the lower cost of
cloud-based services and the lack of the
need to set up separate it
infrastructure the penetration testing
Market is predicted to also grow in the
near future due to the increasing use of
cloud-based Solutions and services for
multiple workloads be it email data
backups CRM and collaborative Services
Cloud deployment exposes software to
more vulnerability and makes it more
accessible to unauthorized users this is
where penetration testing for security
testing comes in with handheld devices
seeming to be the primary device of
choice for the future one such framework
that facilitates this service is the
offensive security back khi net Hunter
so let's take a look at the topics to be
covered in today's video on khi net
Hunter we start with a small
introduction to what khaliif net Hunter
is followed by going through the
different versions of K net Hunter we
then learn about the different
components in the K net Hunter framework
and some of the most helpful attacks or
features that are featured in this
distribution finally we take a look at
the pros and cons of K net Hunter as a
whole before we get started with the
video be sure to subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update again so let's get started with
what is khi net
Hunter KH net Hunter is the very first
Android penetration testing framework
for Android smartphones because net
Hunter is an open source project
developers can freely utilize it without
fearing copyright infringements or other
threats the project grants access to the
Kali toolkit to compatible Android
devices which allows penetration testing
furthermore net Hunter provides several
unique capabilities unavailable on other
Hardware
platforms a userland refers to space
outside of an operating system kernel
meaning anything that doesn't have root
access we can use an app to system
supported on Nexus or OnePlus and rooted
Android phones while this is pretty
incredible there are some limitations to
this in general you can communicate with
the instance of whatever Linux device
you want via SSH or VNC using kly net
Hunter the best device for hackers is an
Android phone installed by K Linux
because mobile phones are more
convenient and portable than laptops for
personal purposes the net Hunter
interface also allows users to work
easily with complicated configuration
files through a local web Apache
interface aside from this functionality
modified Kernels at Android 802.11
wireless injections and securely linked
preconfigured VPN Services comprise a
strong network security breakthrough and
a separate Dropbox with K Linux
constantly at your
disposal we now have a basic
understanding of what K Linux net Hunter
is however there isn't a single
distribution to learn about here K Linux
net Hunter has multiple different
versions depending on the device at the
hands of the users let's cover them in
more
detail so let's cover them in more
detail while K net Hunter functions as a
portable operating system designed for
penetration testing there can be other
tools you want that isn't pre-installed
to solve this problem there is a net
Hunter store at the address store.net
hunter.com this function is the same as
a Google Play Store on Android or app
stores on iPhones except the difference
is that the tools in this repository are
more in line with ethical hacking and
netw
penetration the first of the three
versions that net Hunter provides is the
net Hunter rootless this works on almost
all devices without any issues the
number of tools available in this
version is the lowest among the three we
then have net Hunter light which
requires root privileges to work
properly doesn't need any custom kernel
flashing to power up and has
comparatively more tools than net Hunter
rootless finally we have the original
net Hunter package with all the tools
available at its
disposal however your device must have
root privileges and the custom net
Hunter kernel to install this
version as we can clearly see the more
open our device settings and preferences
are the more tools K net Hunter can work
with root privileges provide
administrative access to many
functionalities that net Hunter can and
leverage and ultimately perform Network
penetration with some tools are
exclusive to the original net Hunter
core and net Hunter light so you may
have to cross check your requirements
before installing any version on your
device now that you have covered the
different versions of K net Hunter let
us cover its different components and
how they help in the working of this
distribution we look at the various net
Hunter components which are effectively
the building pieces of net Hunter's
operation net Hunters roam comprises of
various pieces that communicate and rely
on one another to function properly
below you will look at the three
components that comprise net Hunter the
first is a modified Android kernel
followed by net Hunter Android app and
finally but not least the Ki Linux chro
itself let's examine these in
depth the program that provides a UI to
simplify the user task is a graphical
component of net Hunter which is its
Android app the software provides a
straightforward interface for
controlling the K Linux CH route the
fact that it has a simple eyi does not
imply that it is not capable are
performing complex tasks this
application contains all the
configuration files necessary by net
Hunter and is transferred to the SD card
during the first run aside from the UI
the program also serves as a bootup
service allowing the server to activate
when the device boots
up the next in line is the custom
Android kernel the kernel is a system
component that allows applications to
link to Hardware that meet users needs
aside from facilitating communication
the kernel also maintains system
resources Now the default kernels inside
Android do not supply at all utilities
for security and
exploitation still with a custom Android
kernel any device can be empowered with
unique features which are not accessible
in the stock
bu now we have the Ki CH root CH root
essentially a full K Linux installation
that allows Android to share network
storage and other resources the K Linux
Chu is effectively the heart of net
Hunter and the configuration settings
have been updated so that net Hunter
functions seamlessly with the Android
ecosystem net Hunter has a chro manager
that simplifies the download and
installation of chro this component is
stored in an internal app storage region
and one must meet the installation space
requirements now that you have covered
the different components of net Hunter
let us cover some of the tools that
distribution offers that may be used in
penetration
testing at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap stands for network mapper and
is a free and open- Source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
who also find it useful for tasks such
as Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime it is most beneficial in
the early stage of exploitation where a
hacker must figure out the possible
entry point to a system before running
the necessary exploits uses raw IP
packets in novel ways to determine what
hosts are available on the network what
services are being run what hosts are
offering Etc it was designed to scan
large networks but it also works fine
against single host moving on we have
mitm framework mitm or man in the work
framework provides a One-Stop shop for
man in the middle and network attack
while updating and improving existing
attacks and techniques originally built
to address the significant shortcomings
of other tools it's been almost
completely Rewritten from scratch to
provide a modular and easily extendable
framework that anyone can use to
implement their own version of a man in
the- Middle attack it contains built-in
SMB HTTP and DNS servers that can be
controlled and used by various
plugins the next tool at hand is the CeX
manager it stands for the k
desktop
experience K net Hunter desktop
experience puts the Ki Linux desktop in
the palm of your hand it provides the
graphical user interface or GUI of K
desktop on your Android device making
penetration relatively easier for people
not comfortable with the command
line however the major tools all include
command line functions so this is more
of a convenience inclusion rather than a
functional one finally we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systemic
vulnerabilities on networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems with Metasploit
the ethical hacking team can use rade or
custom code and introduce it into a
network to probe for weaker spots as
another flavor of threat hunting once
the flaws are identified and documented
the information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and and prioritize
Solutions we now have a very clear
understanding of what K net Hunter is
and its features let's cover some of the
pros and cons of this particular
framework when it comes to the
advantages net Hunter provides features
that are not by default included in the
original kernels of Android phones the
new tools can be used to perform Network
penetration and system checks for
security
vulnerabilities qualcom checks and
Snapdragon have monitor support in abled
monom would helps listen to wireless
traffic and capture data packets which
can then be unencrypted and snooped
on the Kernel Builder's presence assess
the easy creation of kernels that are
not yet available to the public
similarly the use of gitlab CLI or
command line interface speeds up the
release timelines it allows the input of
other developers making the bugs washing
process easier and the development of
the tools more
collaborative the human interface device
Hardware is fully supported by default
but it must be enabled and configured
through user Space
controls so when it comes to the
disadvantages of K net Hunter so not
every Android phone is supported as part
of the official net Hunter release
therefore be cautious while downloading
and running them since the wrong net
Hunter may break the phone in some very
rare
circumstances because some internal WiFi
systems do not allow monitor mode or
data packet injection an external USB
Wi-Fi adapter may be required Prov for
some devices who want to pursue wireless
network penetration Professionals in
security testing penetration testing and
ethical hacking utilize Linux as the
preferred operating system provides
several configurable distributions that
mu May configure based on your end use K
Linux and parat Os are two popular
penetration testing distributions while
these operating systems each have unique
offerings the overall Choice can differ
between Personnel thanks to the various
tools and Hardware specifications today
we will look at both these distributions
and settle on the perfect choice for
each type of user let's go through the
agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare
Linux and parro security OS thereby
making a clear-cut conclusion on which
OS is perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open-source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information secur security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and a
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the K Linux
stop while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parad
secur SEC operating
system paret security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the demian's
testing branch and uses a custom Harden
Linux
kernel par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightwe distribution that can
work under rigorous hardware and
software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date a
rolling release distribution such as
pirate security OS follows the same
concept it provides the most recent
Linux kernel and software versions as
soon as they become
available with a basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parad security
OS
the latest version of K Linux comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause scal Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that ki's armm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integ greeted with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts par security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system Act is the second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latex Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parat O development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reason enough parot security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different deop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those UNAM familiar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as a main UI for a
distribution being highly modular in
nature one can use parad security OS
while adding another desktop environment
that they find appealing while K Linux
has only a single option par security
has provided two optimized bills with M
desktop and KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight
this implies that it takes significantly
less disk space and computing power to
function correctly with as little as 320
MB of ram required in reality paratos is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine parat is
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux features are great but what about
performance
real world metrics let us compare both
these operating systems directly with
respect to their Hardware specifications
and
usability in the end we can decide on
what distribution is fit for each type
of
user for our first point of comparison
let's take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature RAM usage is a very
important facet while K Linux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parent security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos the take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended dis
storage of minimum of 20 GB in K Linux
and a minimum of 15 GB in parro security
so they can install all the tools
necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parage security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux
being a decade old penetration testing
distribution K Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature par Security on the other hand
is still growing and it is garnering
much more interest among veteran
penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard disk Storage parro
security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parro
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devot massive
resources to either their virtual
machine or on their laptop hard disk
directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional envir environment
which may or may not be very useful for
new beginners one can decide to go with
par security if they want to go with a
very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
securi desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire
intricacies
if you are a Linux developer or you are
preparing for a Linux developer role so
this video is for you hello everyone and
welcome back to another video by simply
learn this is anub and in this video we
will be learning about Linux interview
questions but before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn so without further Ado let's begin
and see what's in it for you
first we will see the introduction to
Linux after that we will see Trends and
recent changes in Linux
commands moving ahead we will see how to
become a Linux developer after that we
will see the opportunities and salaries
of Linux
developers and after that we will see
Linux command interview
questions Linux platform gives its open
source Natures has integrated a wide
range of innovation Minds who have given
their best to introduce world changing
ideas into
reality Linux is basically an operating
system which is popular for its
efficiency as well as its
performance it can run on various
Hardware platforms manufactured by IBM
Intel and
HP now let's see some Trends and recent
changes in Linux commands
Linux is super Computing the development
and deployment of Linux powered super
computors is a trend that shows no signs
of abing given the flexibility structure
of the Linux system as well as the
compatibilities it has the usage of
Linux as a super computer operating
system is guaranteed to remain one of
the most important Linux Trends in
2022 let's see the next Point New Linux
based
Hardware the Linux platform has gained a
repulsion since Raspberry Pi and
Chromebooks gained the attention of the
particular domain of viewers these Linux
based components are breaking new
grounds as the new pass thanks to their
small from size and ability to perform
routine task with ease the platform has
now witnessed Advanced implementations
throughout the prior calendar year now
the next point we will be discussing is
the cloud and the Linux although Linux
is popular in the technological
Community it is going to continue to
increase in popularity in line with the
open-minded techniques of
2022 as cloud-based Technologies and the
Linux system are so interconnected the
Linux system is expected to grow with
the cloudbased alternative now let's see
the next point which is Chromebooks and
Chrome OS
Chrome OS has transformed into the most
flexible operating system available in
the market Chrome OS just obtain the
ability to connect with Google Play
Store and run just about any Android app
giving user one of the most strange web
ciruit experience possible talking into
consideration the improvements on the
operating system it is too soon going to
be on a quick survey towards
possibilities becoming the most flexible
platform compatible on running Android
and Linux
softwares now let's see how to become a
Linux
developer let us take a look at the
required skills needed to make a career
as a Linux developer first one is learn
C programming the first and the foremost
thing which is needed is learn C
programming most of the part of Linux
are written in C if you want to
contribute lowlevel parts of the system
you should should know the Assembly
Language as well however intentionally
it is important to learn the C language
next step is to learn algorithms and
data structure to become a Linux
developer you should have a fundamental
knowledge of data structure and
algorithms and algorithm is basically a
step-by-step approach to solve a
particular problem on the other hand
data structure works on organization
data both these components help the
programmers to solve the problem within
a
minute The Next Step you should learn is
operating
system now that you have acquired some
knowledge of the programming the next
thing on your to-do list should be learn
everything about the operating system
and then do some
programming competitive programming can
help you Master's algorithms and data
structures it also shows you how to
solve a program in a short short period
of time a competitive programmer must be
able to solve an issue in a short amount
of time now let's see the opportunities
and salaries of Linux
programmers when it comes to Linux
professionals you have two choices you
can either work towards becoming a
developer or you can go into
Administration furthermore the
professional option are not limited to
Linux platform they Encompass the wide
range of applications
the following are the areas where hiring
managers are looking for hiring Linux
developers first one is system
architecture Linux system architecture
salary in India rang between 6.3 lakhs
to 44 lakh with an average annual salary
of 21.1 lakhs the next one is system
administration the average salary of a
system administration in India range
between R 2.4 lakh perom to rupes 4.5
lakh perm the next one
is web developer and development Linux
developer average annual salary in India
range from rupees 3 lakh to 8.9
lakhs and for desktop and app
development aage starting salary for
Linux developer and app developer is in
India is rupees 3 lakh per year now
we'll move ahead with the Linux command
interview questions the first question
that we will discuss is what is Linux
Linux is a uni based open source
operating system Linux to walls was the
first to introduce Linux the primary
goal of Linux was to give a free and
lowcost operating system for people who
couldn't buy Windows iOS or
Unix now the next question is Define
Linux kernel is it legal to addit Linux
kernel the answer is the Linux kernel is
a low-level Software System it is used
to keep track of resources and give a
user
interface yes it is legal to edit Linux
kernel Linux is released under the
journal public license which is GPL and
any project which is released under GPL
can be edited and Modified by the end
users let's move on to the next
question which is what is Li l o l l
denotes Linux loader it is basically
Linux boot loader which loads Linux
operating system into a main memory to
start execution most of the computer
systems are featured with boot loaders
for certain versions for Mac OS or
Windows OS so if you want to use Linux
OS you have to install a special boot
loader for it when a computer gets
started bios conducts small initial test
and transfer control to the master boot
roader for from here L loads the Linux
OS and started the benefit of utilizing
L loo is that it ensures a quick boot of
the Linux operating system moving ahead
let's move on to the next question which
is what are the basic components of
Linux the following are the basic
components of Linux first one is share
it is a Linux interpreter which is used
for executing commands the next one is
Kernel kernel is the co-art of the
operating system which is used to manage
hardware and
operations after that the next one is
system utilities these are the software
functions which help users to manage
their computers the next one is GUI GUI
donates graphical user interface through
which the user can interact with the
system but unline CLI GUI compresses
buttons images and text boxes for
interaction the next one is application
programs software programs are designed
to complete a particular
task now the next question is which
shell are used in
Linux the following are the most common
types of shell used in in Linux the
first one is fish friendly interactive
shell offers some special features such
as web based configuration fully
scriptable and auto suggestions with
clean scripts the next one is Bash
borine again shell is the default for
most of the Linux distributions the next
one is zsh z shell offers unique
features like startup files file name
generation login or log out watching and
closing comments the next one is
CHS cshell follows C like syntax and has
features like spelling correction as
well as job
control now let's move on to the next
question what is swab space swab space
is the extra space utilized by Linux to
temporarily keep concurrently running
processes when Ram space is sufficient
when you start a program it is stored in
Ram so that the CPU can quickly retrieve
data if you have more running programs
then Ram can accommodate the swap space
is used to store these programs the
processor will now search for the RAM
and swap space for data swap space is
used in the form of execution of ram by
Unix let's move move on to the next
question which is differentiate between
dos and Bash Bash is a command which is
K sensitive and dos commands are not K
sensitive in bash there are eight
characters for file name post fixed with
three characters for the extension and
in DOS no naming conventions are used
again bash is used as an escape
character and is used in the form of
directory
sper now let's move on to the next
question which is what is file
permission in Linux the following are
the three types of permission in Linux
first one is the read it allows its user
to open and read the file the next one
is write it allows its user to open and
edit the file and the third and the last
one is execute it allows its use user to
run the
file the next question
is what are iode and process ID inode is
a unique name provided by the operating
system for each file similarly process
ID is also a unique ID provided to each
process what are Linux directory
commands given below are the five main
directory commands in Linux the first
one is pwt it displays the path of the
present working directory the next one
is is list all the directories and files
in the present working directory CD it
is used for changing the present working
directory
rmd it deletes a directory and
mkdir it is used to create a new
directory mkd is also known as make
directory now let's move on to the next
question what are the various processes
States in
Linux given below are the process states
of
Linux the first one denotes ready the
process is ready to
run the second one running is the
process has been
executed the third one is wait or
blocked this shows the process is
waiting for the input after that it's
completed or
terminated this process shows com the
process is completed execution or was
terminated by the system the last one is
zombie the process terminated by the
information is still available in the
process
table let's move on to the next
question what are Process Management
System call calls the following are the
system calls used to manage the process
the first function is Fork function it
is used for creating a new process then
next is a exec function which is used
for executing a new program the third
one is a wait function wait until the
process completes the
execution after that it's exit function
it is used to exit from the process
after that it's get P ID function get
the unique process ID of the
process and the last one is get PP ID
function gets the parent process unique
ID let's move on to the next
question what are the redirection
operators the redirection operator is
used for redirecting the output of the
specific command as an input to another
command the following are the two ways
to use this the first one is this symbol
which is overwrites the files existing
content or creates a new one the second
one is the symbol which shows the add
the new content to the end of an
existing file or create a new one let's
move on to the next question which is
explain a latch a latch is a temporary
storage of device that is controlled by
a training signal which can be either
stored as zero or One A latch is a
primarily used to retain State
information and has two stable States
high output or one or low output or zero
as long as a latch is powered on it can
store one piece of
data the next question is is what is
microprocessor a microprocessor is a
device which is used for
execution instructions it is a single
chip device that fetches the
instructions from the memory decodes set
and executes it the following are the
three basic functions which are carried
out by a
microprocessor the first one is addition
subtraction multiplication and division
are example of mathematical operations
the next one is make decision based on
the circumstances and then jump to the
new different instructions as needed
last one is move data from one position
in memory to
another now let's move on to the next
question how to rename files in Linux
there is no such particular command for
renaming a file in Linux however you can
use thee copy or move command to renew a
file the First Command which we use is
move
command we write it like dollar sign MV
which donate at
move old name and then the new name of
the file like this only we will write a
copy command in that there will be a
dollar sign CP means copy old name of
the file and then the new name of the
file like that only if we want to delete
a command we'll write dollar sign RM
which donates as remove and the file
name let's move on to the next
question how to write the output of a
command to a file you have to use the
redirection operator to do this write
dollar sign the command which you want
to use and the greater sign and then the
file
name the next question is how to copy
files to a floppy disk the following
steps will guide you to copy file to a
floppy disk the first one is Mount to
floppy disc the second one is copy the
files and the last one is unmount the
floppy
disc let's move on to the next
question how how should we identify
which shell you are
using open the terminal and run dollar
sign e c o which is Echo and then again
dollar sign and shell all in
capital let's move on to the last and
final question for this interview
question
series how would you sort the entities
in a text file in ascending order you
can do this by using the sort command
for this you have to write the dollar
sign sort simple. text simple. text is
the file name that I'm using here you
can use the name of your file you which
you want to do a sending order operation
so here we wrap up Kali Linux course if
you have any queries feel free to add
them in the comment section below and
our experts will be happy to help
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
more digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here